[Music]
cnr meeting of the 18th of october
move from the bottom of the page
any comments there to page three
four
five
okay
yeah i mean i think it's already on
it's already existed somewhere we can we
can produce and we should be producing a
list of money's health
in the members bulletin on a monthly
basis but if you haven't been having
that that might be down to the fact that
the previous strategic enabling officer
left and it's one of those jobs that's
fallen down the crack so i'm sure that
starts again
yeah it was in friday's
on this day thank you
are the members notified when the
application comes in and is being
discussed or are we notified after the
offices of negotiated 106 because the
county seem to be getting a very big
share
and we're not sort of consulted about
at what point
at what point do the ward members get
told
and they're consulted on
that varies cancer depending on the
application and the
type of 106. um but
uh in general i thought that the members
were
notified as soon as there's sort of a
draft agreement in place no no
chair
no that doesn't happen we've got
approaching i think it'll be a thousand
houses at the top of westwood oh
uh are we not being consulted yet
and it concerns me that we can seem to
be taking a bite and there seems to be
negotiation with the officers
and i think the members need to this
needs to happen at an early stage but
i'm not sure how we trigger that so that
it
it happens in every case i don't think
it's gonna opposite it varies because
that's the loophole and the members
don't hear until it's too late
i've never seen it in respect of my
board and i know there's been
development going on
i would think it's quite simple we asked
for a report to come to this next
meeting with details
because we all seem to be in the dark
counselor dark first thank you just to
say that actually that was quite
and gravity parish council were
consulted or the chair at least was
by the planning officer on what if
certain development was allowed to go
ahead what they would spend the money on
and
i didn't know anything about it when
they asked me so surely if they're
pulling feelers out to
the parish councils then it would be
prudent to
allow the warp members in on the whole
act as well because i looked well
ignorant as i was um because i didn't
have a clue what they're talking about
and in that spot i've got to go back to
laura davis about it but um
yeah i don't know if we had set
stringent guidelines then at least
everyone would know where they are
closely yeah thank you i've just looked
at the members of the bulletin it's not
there yeah sorry i'm just going to come
back it was um i was talking to
councilmember at the time when you
started the conversation that was lead
member members allowances that was in
there so i wanted to check when it was
lasting
i didn't use it
can i ask if we're getting the list
can we have the cutoff date
because that's very important because
otherwise it just returns to the
developer
and um
there was one thing the um
just trying to think what the other
thing was now um sorry
i'll come back to you i remember
anyone else wishing to speak on that
page
six
yeah
one more again um
the costume figures for the repairs to
the boat were they giving out
[Music]
haven't i don't know the figure off the
top of my head yeah but obviously the
work's done i'll get richard to
circulate the costs
[Music]
i remember what it was um can we also if
we're getting this list of sections
can the planning department tell us
where section 106 hasn't been signed
because
there is an extremely important
development in biddeford where
it can't go ahead until the developers
signed the section 106 and build a new
school
which bit of a desperately needs and in
primary school
they won't sign him and i just want to
be kept in the loop because we've had
another planning application come just
over here
where they say they're built to school
and i don't want us i don't want that
school to sit between the cracks and i
would like us to have an update on where
section 116 have actually got to
yeah so in the list has been previously
circulated it's only section 106 comes
held as opposed to section 106 once
negotiated
so
the list that you've had would be the
money that we have in the bank for
off-site rec or
and things like that rather than the
full list of section 106s that have been
negotiated but might not have been
signed or the monies might not have met
the trigger file you might not bet the
trigger points are having money
so
that would be quite an epic
document
can i just ask one further thing then
because
this section 106
the large one is between ambition road
and cleveland road behind atlantic
village as i still call
it's 750 houses now if they haven't
signed the section 106 what does that do
to our local plan and the
housing the five-year housing because we
will never ever catch up with the other
sign that what happens then
i
stand by my suggestion that we have a
full report on 106 at the next meeting
it's clearly critical to all of us
thank you
okay
page seven
so
that's that are you happy they decided
to turn correct record all these show
thank you
christy those in favor please show
sweetheart
hey
those against
those abstaining
free
thank you
that's what happens when you try to move
it on
item three action list
it is there on your paperwork is paid
gate
any comments there too from anyone
you should have read it before you got
here i had
reading
it's not been done
yeah sure we can make sure it's done i
i thought it was being
circulated on a monthly basis but if
that's not the case we'll just make sure
it is
thank you
right
nothing to say on that one
move on item four
public contributions i've not been
informed of any
[Music]
six declarations of interest your own
adults i don't intend to go into it
item seven
[Music]
agreement of the agenda i don't think
there's any part two items so we can
agree be happy with that situation
item eight urgent matters of information
to be brought forward
i have one
uh i'm not particularly happy and
comfortable
in coming into the uh words coveted spot
in the country
uh
we really should be having this meeting
on zoom in my opinion at the moment
i do note with interest that
apologies seem to be coming in for full
council next week
i can understand why
and i would suggest to make a proposal
that we instruct our chief executive to
write to our mp
asking him to take it up as the worst
affected district in the country that we
do not have to have these meetings as we
are that we can have soon meetings
and i would suggest that the chief
executive says
that he is well aware of our mp's
ability and accustomed to use of soon
chancellor brennan well there's nothing
like a bit of sarcasm deserved to wind
him up but never mind yes i totally
agree with that but i think also we
should contact the lga and say that
we're going to take unilateral action if
they don't do something better it's all
very well having a blanket
a thing for the whole country it's just
it's just a nonsense i think you have to
have horses for courses here and i
totally agree with you it was my
daughter's a nurse in the hospital i i
do feel very uncomfortable about
coming to
these meetings it's not very well worth
wearing a mask that's just not good
enough i'm afraid we were all sat here
now god knows what the contacts we've
had i know i'm free of it i was tested
last uh
last thursday when i visited my house so
but but that's uh i only last 48 hours i
test so that's that's still good so i
totally support what you're saying
steve uh thanks jeff well we've got a
meeting with our mp on wednesday morning
so we haven't raised it for the mp
um unfortunately as as members are aware
the legislation doesn't permit us to
hold zoom meeting so we've got no
alternative but to continue with
committee meetings and full council uh
face-to-face now we've now
turned some members talk about just not
attending uh you've got some very
critical decisions uh coming forward in
the next couple of meetings
notwithstanding uh you've got budget
meetings uh many decisions can't be
delegated the only way you can do things
to delegate is to delegate
to officers which previously members
haven't been supportive of
notwithstanding are there some decisions
such as budget decisions which only full
council can take so for example it's
your meeting or council meeting
monday evening you've got the second of
the council tax base which are
pre-sector authorities the county
council parish town councils the police
commissioner and the fire authority need
that information from this council
you've also got uh decisions to take
around leisure services and if those
decisions are delayed or not taken that
will
significantly impact our ability to
operate leisure services from next april
so check and raise it with the mp and
your right to the mp but at the moment
we have stuck with the legislation as is
yeah the lga have been lobbying
uh government on all councils behalf on
this subject matter
but
up until now it hasn't uh nothing's
changed
that's why i said go to the mp it's
where it can be useful to us
i mean the other alternative is for
members to vote with their feet and not
turn up make it non-core at the meeting
yeah i wouldn't say that would shake
things up but
through the chair surely it wouldn't
because officers would just have to take
those decisions would you is that how it
works no
no
well you can't just take decisions to
change uh decisions to be
delegated to officers you've got to hold
a full council meeting to change the
constitution so what's your plan b if
nobody turns up
well it's not something we've considered
that members just won't simply turn out
that's true
yes yeah i i don't agree with you
i think you know we are where we are
with it if you look at the latest
figures um it's mostly in young people
in the schools um it's not so much in
our generation we're taking all the
precautions we can there's the chief
executive said we've got a lot of
decisions to make i've been in on lga
meetings where it's always gone and the
government is just not responding they
have made up their mind that we've got
to carry on
and
i would think it would be suddenly
irresponsible for us not to turn up to
meetings
because we have got function to continue
to carry out
so i i can't support that mr leader
well i
can't i don't think we can take a vote
on something that i raised can we
[Music]
i would ask you to raise it most
strong a lot of people a lot of us
aren't quite worried about
you know one of our members go down with
it we look a bit sick
and they will too
anyway
have you had any um
communication from the county council at
all
consultations we're just now
uh vis-a-vis the link centers in in
north covenant and rs and torres with
biddeford and holdsworthy uh i've had um
constituents approach me about
their proposals to close them we're
supposed to be consulted on that i don't
recall ever seeing this on any agenda
item whether we were uh
their proposals i mean they didn't talk
about
this one reopening i don't think that's
possible they removed all the equipment
out of it all the gear out of it so i
don't know what's going on there but
certainly there's some shenanigans going
on in the country although i know it's a
cost-cutting exercise obviously it is
but you know that's not good enough in
terms of uh our mental health with the
area
kendall james yeah well coach
was on the radio devon this morning um
reiterating what i've been told and that
is it's highly likely that they're
written
from what i think it's wednesday in
county hall and the proposal at the
moment is that they will keep barnstable
alpha comb and biddeford open
and holdsworthy will move to a new site
um as a trustee of the youth center we
have put a bit in to actually take that
on it homesworthy and all i've heard is
it will be moving to another building
and we're not sure whether that's going
to be the youth center or a different
county council building within
holdsworthy but holdsworthy will
continue because
those of us who run the youth center the
youth club and the other services like
dementia we're determined that it will
continue in holdsworthy and as i
understand the other three
it's highly likely they will continue i
can't say they will i will say it's
highly likely they will
david
well once again i asked the original
question have we been formally consulted
by the county council so i recall no
dude
i believe there's some information
circulated on members bulletin
a couple of weeks ago
i've seen that that came through
what does it stand so far but i've seen
another report which is contradicts a
lot of that and the report itself is
very very poor uh reported indeed it's
not satisfactory
but there we are i've listened to what
you're saying
okay we can move on to the agenda in
full now item nine
tdc carbon friend faces 10 to 23.
off you go thank you chair
evening everybody prairie police
presents members and the outcome of our
first carbon audit taken by the
authorities since 2016.
members will of course be aware that uh
of our commitment to zero carbon and we
really can't make progress progress on
this in a meaningful way unless we know
what our carbon usage is in all the
areas of our organization
we've
used updated government guidelines and
put together this inventory
and the report outlines the various
scopes that need to be included in the
assessment so essentially there are
three main scopes scope one really
relates to fuel combustion and emissions
from company vehicles scope 2 relates to
purchased electricity and the first two
scopes are mandatory in the reporting
the third scrub is much wider but it's
discretionary and i've outlined in the
report what admissions have been
included in our scope three these are
fairly standard for local authorities of
our size and nature however there's
likely to be some expansion and
refinement of this scope in the coming
years this has really been quite a
difficult day to gathering exercise at
times but it will be easy going forward
as we put in place processes for better
collecting this information on an annual
basis going forward
ultimately we're putting forward to
members and the result of our audit for
2021 a figure of
3875 tons of carbon and this is our
starting point for looking at how we
must effectively reduce this over the
next eight years
some members will not this represents a
significant jump in carbon usage since
um this was last reported in
we've not 2016
able to find the basis of these figures
previously reported but it could be
partly down to the revised guidance used
to determine the figure but we have
included this previous figure um in the
report as it is a matter of public
record so we need to acknowledge that
even if we can't um fully explain the
significant increase
now while
the tonnage of carbon being reported may
seem daunting the areas where the most
significant usage is taking place hasn't
really come as a surprise we know where
the challenges lie it's our estate and
it's transport especially our waste
service
and it's also our procured materials
there's a lot of work being done in all
of these areas overseen by the the
member climate working group we've
already considered this report and have
put it forward to to see an awful review
the report provides an outline of some
of the areas we're progressing at the
moment and we've commissioned surveys of
our properties to identify opportunities
for improving energy efficiency
and we're monitoring the emergency low
impact technology on our waste fleet
not a viable option at the current time
but this is a rapidly changing area and
we'll be looking at options for
expanding our pv capacity to reduce and
if possible offset our own usage
so at the current time we're reporting
the outcome of this audit to to members
in order to focus understanding and
efforts going forward and to drive the
necessary changes within the authority
and i'm not going to cover anything else
now so it's thought to be best just to
just fill this open for any comments or
queries and i'll do my best to answer
those myself and but as you can imagine
it was our sustainability and climate
officers carried out this significant
piece of work for us so um anything too
technical it might be best that i
consult with donald and come back to you
on that but um i will do my best so
happy to take any questions
to know the carbon cost of collecting
all the recycling balanced against the
savings
that's the question that i don't expect
you to ever answer but it's quite
interesting to know whether there is a
game on the right side
and chair that's something that's been
discussed in the member climate working
group and in the past we're
almost a victim of our own success in
terms of our recycling rates the the
more recycling we're doing the food
collection service as well actually
means additional carbon and that will
come out in this in this audit so it is
a balancing and it's a balancing act um
but yeah that would be interesting
council once i do
any other committee members wishing to
speak i'll move to
yep driver thank you
um
yeah as chair of the uh
climate working group i'd just like to
thank jan for preparing his report
and also donna simply for the work she's
done in doing the carbon survey
and i just commend this report to
members it's the first it's the vital
information we need to embark on our
journey towards net zero
and uh
i look forward to seeing further reports
in progress thanks very much
okay i think this report is for noting
okay
yeah counselor love leather
thank you chair not just a question for
john really
um on the list that we've got in the
report
that arrives at
3875 tons there's nothing shown for
offset emissions
but we've got solar panels on riverbank
house would that look good
and now
cancel out the yes it will um we're
currently have an application with
offgen
and to apply for the credits
and for the to the
system that's on top of the bank house
and they've asked for a lot of support
and information at the moment we think
we'll be able to get credits for that
and whether that actually means it's a
reduction in the usage of our
electricity at the riverbank or it's
actually an offset that we could use i i
we're we're sending that back to the
grid we're not sure yet so we're unable
to report on that at the present time
but certainly um offset emissions will
be something that will be reporting in
the future one of those areas once we've
done once
[Music]
yeah i just want to say something about
the offset um
well obviously if you look on page 13
and rob
trees in that
on sunday morning i went to see uh one
skateboard park in biddeford
um i've given some my council of grant
and the biddeford sustainability group
the planned trees on torres land
and i wonder if every other councillor
should go back to their parish councils
or if they've got local groups and just
say can you identify any small areas of
land because it isn't a huge area of
land but they are planting
trees and bushes on it they're very keen
actually as well
i wonder if they could be added in time
if it's our land then then then yes and
one of just as an aside and chair one of
the things that was discussed at the
last climate member group was around the
jubilee trees
and so there is some information that
will be going out and on that shortly so
that that's to encourage um parish
councils community groups that sort of
thing to plant trees not all of that
will be uh we'll be able to claim and
our own offset
but that's you know trees are good
okay
that item was promoting so we've noted
it we moved on to item
right um thank you chad um i'm looking
for approval from members for a new fee
that has come about from a new piece of
legislation mobile homes requirement for
managers of site to be a fit and proper
person england regulations 2020 as this
is a new fee it does require specific
consideration and approval before it
could be added to our list of fees and
charges
these provisions applied to residential
caravan parks users used either
exclusively residentially or those used
for both residential and holiday
purposes
six operators within cbc area will be
covered by these new provisions members
might have seen recent cases in the
press thankfully not entourage relating
to issues of intimidation and criminal
practices carried out by mobile home
operators currently licensed licence
holders are not subject to something
called a fit and proper personal check
this is a requirement in other licensing
regimes such as for taxis and for houses
in multiple occupation the new
legislation extends these checks to
mobile home operators and brings it in
line with these other types of licenses
so we therefore have experience of
carrying out these checks and processes
in place to manage um the
the checks
and the report gives details of the
types of offenses that would fall under
these checks but relate to a wide range
of criminal offences and financial
misconduct the guidance for these
regulations recommend that a fit and
proper personal assessment fee policy
and fit and property termination policy
is adopted and these are given along
with the report we are proposing a fee
of 215 pounds and a breakdown of how
this amount has arrived that is also
given in the report the fee should be
cost neutral to the council and it's
intended that this will be reviewed on
an annual basis as part of the normal
fees and charges review process
this registration lasts for five years
and the operators affected by these new
requirements have already been notified
once the fees have been agreed hopefully
tonight we'll begin the process and
begin to process the applications for
the register if members have any
questions i will be happy to try to
answer them
[Music]
for a number of years but not from in
recent years i've acted through the
weapon wheels of winning but i think it
was far enough again i don't have to
worry about it
but i do mention it
uh right opens the meeting
okay
i didn't quite catch what you could say
um but without the register will it be
available
uh it will be a public register i rather
fit the proper person checks out public
registers at the moment
that we have problems with the caravan
site that's quite close to me it's a
dog-friendly caravan side
but they had obsessions there they got
out and killed several sheep when they
joined the farm and the company would
not
would not take any responsibility for
what happened um i understand that's
they've never changed towns and they
know how possible or something um but we
we've had quite a lot of trouble um we
don't worry in the shoe and several were
killed and they just didn't want to know
so it hardly seemed like there was
anybody
nearly as big as what the village of
ritual is
um
but somebody does take responsibility
for that small battery
because the
farmer caught the dogs
and the police said they couldn't shoot
them once they call them and they they
just took them back
and eventually they did move on but
nobody from that business would take
responsibility for the dog's
attacking team
and it was a hell of a
mess brenton
thank you um
yes if if we approve somebody as a fit
and proper person do we have any
legal liability should they
fall short of the
expected
requirements in dealing with their sites
i can sponsor that chair
no
we don't yeah there's no comeback
it's just it's a legal requirement on
the operator to meet these these
provisions right so it's
yes it's
like the police aren't responsible for
speeding they're responsible for
enforcing speeding
just some of these criteria here i mean
must be quite difficult to
check on really quality action all that
type of thing
would you
you know the thesis is quite small for
that amount of um
information that we require in order to
approve something
we have ways of of carrying out these
checks yeah yeah as i say we do it for
taxi drivers hmo license holders so
that's all in place okay thank you
on the question of the fee it's done by
sort of
we think it's the right figure at the
moment
um
may i suggest that
you're going to get sort of a lot of
applications now
and in five years time there will be
quite a lot of gain okay
before it come just before the five
years
could we be told how much time whether
we're losing money or making money on it
rather than just adding on inflation all
the time which is what we tend to do
chair certainly probably housing fees
and a lot of the of chris's licensing
fees is actually a process every year
reviewing the time spent on on certain
matters we will definitely review these
after the first
batch of applications because
it has been a little bit clean
in the air job in terms of um the time
that we've allocated to various aspects
that is based on other fit and proper
person checks but we will be checking
for this so so after a year um we will
be
reviewing this but that will be part of
our normal
fees and charges review process thank
you
thank you
thank you very much i did raise a
question with our officer before the
meeting because i hate
uh appearing like we're
trying to trick someone up about the
number of sites that have been
identified and i thought it was quite
low
um and she has given her
me an undertaking that she will check
and confirm
that these and she doesn't have
knowledge of all the caravan sites to
hand
so i think that's an important thing
because the list i was shown didn't
include some of the larger sites that we
have
in our neck of the woods
and with this fit and proper
registration
the
215 pounds is that a one-off fee or is
this an annual fee for them
that's question one
question two i presume the
fit and proper registration is attached
to the individual rather than the site
so therefore if there is a change of
hands
um
they would have to re-register the new
new person
um
and finally
do you actually review
uh the conditions on the site on an
annual basis
to confirm that they're in compliance um
because the case 215 pounds easily done
we
carry out uh
the fee is for five years the
registration is for a period of five
years however if there's any change in
license holder um or or management of
the site during that time then its
requirement on the on the the license
holder to notify us of that that change
of um
relevant person and then that fee will
apply to the new checks that are carried
out
um the
inspections
um of the of the caravan sites um
obviously because of covid we haven't
carried them out last year but they are
normally on an annual basis but i do
know that's something that we haven't
done because of because of covert and
staff being them allocated elsewhere
that's something that we'll be getting
back to and once once resources allow
um
so answered all the questions
the other just just to um further i did
quickly check on the um
on one of the policies that have been
provided this this requirement doesn't
apply to
um holiday sites if it's a solely a
holiday site which is one of the
particular sites that you've mentioned
and these provisions don't apply to that
but if there's any other sites that you
think of let me know and there are a
number of exemptions um in the in the
legislation there's any particular sites
you want me to check just send me the
details and i'll speak to my licensing
lead and on my caravan licensing plane
and we'll get that information back to
you
come back tonight i'll just come back
um
what happens when you have a holiday
site
that is utilized
for the council
in acquiring
temporary accommodation
for meeting its statutory housing need
so it is providing residential
accommodation as well as holiday
accommodations because that that site
that we mentioned yeah
actually does that yeah and it's a
temporary use of the site for that that
man basically we're using those units as
as as holiday accommodation it's not
changing its use
and but it's just being used for for our
own temporary accommodation
so i i don't think that would apply
inside i would respectfully say that
you know
the one i'm thinking about i don't have
a particular issue about standards but
i'm quite sure there are others that
might
not
hit them off
so if any members have any particular
concerns or want particular
clarification on any sites just let me
know and i'll speak to my caravan
licensing lead and we'll get that
information back to you thank you very
much
on the
[Music]
to be come under this he had to say then
if torridge is going to let you know
just to clarify these are all in the
world
this is an additional requirement to the
license for certain sites that we
already licensed so we know the sites
that fall under the licensing regime
within torridge anyway and a certain
percentage of those fall under this
additional um legislation
so we already fights have to be licensed
not all sites need to be licensed now
so we already know which sites fall
under this this legislation and they
have been notified that they will
they will
[Music]
you know that's that's already sorted
then yes yes yeah it's it's an
additional check on top of the license
that they already will buy okay
sorry if that wasn't for them
[Music]
can
one
person
um
be a fit and proper person for more than
one site
good question council laws i will have
to check
on that
and get back to you if that's okay
yeah thank you thank you
yeah sorry um jen said that not all
sites qualified i'll just clarify that
it's their sort of site and the sort of
limits on numbers and mobile voters
which make someone qualified or not
can we just clarify that there are a
number of exemptions and to these
requirements and i'll be able to confirm
those with you fully counseling rooms
after this
it's a little bit complicated and
it wasn't included in the report
sorry the other thing was
this
for this
licensing scheme jan or is it someone in
your department and if there's someone
in your department who is it please
i am responsible for that
right i think this one needs moving
please
can someone propose it
[Music]
and
secondly by capturing law
i'll put it to the vote those in favor
please share
that is unanimous thank you
written notice of motion
ages 54 and 55
fascinating the man who's auntie
everything in spending money going
forward he's proposing that we do
something that's the leather up to you
i didn't hear you do you remember
um thank you thank you committee
as the report says um i put this forward
his september
council it did receive a lot of support
to come to this business
but this was first drawn to my attention
back in august
something like that the rspca run in the
campaign
it was somebody who lives in my award
you fought me up and
informed me about it so i looked into it
all
um and now as i said the rspca running
the campaign to get the banning to get
it banned that
animals are giving us prizes
people mention goldfish it's one way or
the hospitals on the fairgrounds you can
go with a goldfish that's carried home
in a plastic bag and then flush down the
lavatory very often
when they find there's nothing nowhere
to keep it so
i thought it
it might seem trivial to some people but
i felt looking into it that
we ought to support this and the rspca
are asking councils to support it
and
it will not cost any money for this
council to add this line to their
leasing agreement and it's it's to any
any of our sites
where we might lease them out for
fairgrounds or whatever
and um
if we if you vote in support of this
that
minor amendment could be made to our
leasing agreements
and we'll write to the government a
whole and ask them
to validate not only on council land but
i think it should be banned nationwide
the giving of animals as prizes
is what it's all about
goldfish
it might seem strange but
for those those of us who may come back
reincarnated you're thankful when you
come back as a goldfish that you
supported this time
thanks chair
i'm already there
right
i s
to clarify
this would include if it was to be held
on
torres grand bowling for a pig at a
village faith yes
right
okay
a lot of people put off
doing the skills for a pig on the basis
that they don't know where to put it
when they win the price so very well if
they get involved with the paperwork
they wouldn't even
what happens to it though
obviously it goes back to full control
i was just agreeing tonight yeah right
but i might just ask
what other live animals have given away
just discussed with local skittles
i mean apart from goldfish
wasn't it if i counted some of the
evidence i saw was puppies and kittens
in various places of the country giving
away surprises and people suddenly end
up with an animal that they didn't know
they were going to get
and not really able to look after it
probably don't want to look after it i
just think it's an antiquated way of
giving prizes out and
as a conclusion says it before that
just to decide whether we want to
support this campaign i think we should
counselor james
[Music]
and puppies cost an absolute fortune and
kittens are astronomical as well so
why would you give them away free
i don't i
i haven't seen this happen
i don't think i've ever seen it
does it actually well they're not giving
away free if you walk to the fairground
you pay to enter the competition to
whatever it might be hooking a duck out
in the water or whatever it is
so when you aren't paying it i mean
they're not giving away freelance but
they gave you things i don't have a
small goal for that expensive
[Music]
our decision stands
it was both i understood
all right put it to the vote those in
favor please show
one two three four five six seven eight
nine
those
against one
abstaining
one
okay
thank you chad thanks committee
we move on that north devil
[Music]
so this is a brief report um to to bring
you up to speed and more visible
support activities
um
we've had previous debates at committee
and i thought this was particularly
timely because the last time we brought
a business support update it was around
providing northern plus with a hundred
thousand pounds to run the business
boost program with quite a lot of debate
about what was going on at that time
so this report gives you the details of
what north dublin has been up to
first the additional restrictions grants
you can see that uh north dakota has
been administering those for us
uh this is the
discussion about schemes given
by the government for us to distribute
to businesses
in an impressive sum
of uh two million two hundred and fifty
three thousand nine hundred and ninety
four pounds distributed to date so it's
quite a lot about activity there
excuse me uh the arg business boots
program that's the one i was just
talking about a second ago so this is a
scheme to help small and start-up
businesses get back on their feet
postcoded
um i've got some more up-to-date figures
here from when the report was written
but we've now engaged with 44 local sme
clients and 36 have had one-to-one
appointments for the business advisor
um of these 44 21 are from torridge and
24 from north devon so again there's
quite a lot of activity going on there
um in the report there's a
selection of uh sort of case studies if
you like that
some of the people will speak to
the kickstart scheme kickstart scheme
was a government initiative to get young
people on universal credit into work and
north devon plus working with
uh basketball chamber of commerce has
been acting as a gateway to that
now this this is a particularly pleasing
scheme really to be honest
in that
we've now had 38 companies approved by
the dwp replacement with 86 placements
in total
of the 86 placements
dwp have matched their clients 51
placements
in the workplace which is great and so
far 16 young people have completed their
six-month placement with and 12 have
been kept on for permanent roles so so
that i think is a
fantastic result for the local economy
the future farm resilience program
that's uh there's a lot of change
proposed
and coming for agriculture and working
with west devon beer
business information point uh we've been
running a programme to
help farmers in their transition
um around the way basic payments are
made
and looking at environmental land land
systems
i think if you talk to graham and the
team this is the most harrowing one for
him because he tends to talk to a lot of
uh shall we
senior farmers who are struggling with
the transition and perhaps don't have
the younger people in their families who
want to take the farms on and this this
is really trying to get them to focus on
what business opportunities there are
for them now and how they might change
their business to make it more
successful for the future
so
you can see some figures in there about
the uh
the way we've been interacting with them
there i think that's a really vital one
and probably most vital for north wplus
in that is developing a bit of a
presence with the agricultural community
and we've also been working with their
devon county council with growth hub as
well which provides one-to-one advice
for us
to follow and follow up for support for
uh small businesses until march 23. so i
i don't really have anything else to say
i'm quite suddenly a report to know the
chair if there's any questions anybody
wants to ask
comments or questions please counselor
christy yeah i think it says pretty good
report actually but could i ask one day
on page 57
potential property development pre-start
venture
yeah
so
so i don't know the exact details of
that one but it's something that
somebody asked the other day when i
wasn't just the north border and this
was somebody exploring an idea
uh so it's a pre-start as in
pre-start-up business
uh to go into a property development
adventure so we've helped that person to
explore the feasibility of their idea
so we're actually funding a property
development
it would appear so yeah
that's interesting
i'm sure that's where the money should
be going i mean the other ones are
really
they are classic small businesses
starters
property developers we all have our own
opinions on them
uh
chair they're they're
[Music]
thank you um page 57 again i mean it's a
great report this i'm very pleased to
read it
um when i talk about the kickstart
scheme
we're talking here about young people
aged 16 to 24 who are paying universal
credit why does those claim a universal
credit i know it's a government scheme
but surely there's lots of 16 to 24s who
are not playing universal credit would
welcome
based on one of these schools in the
scheme
why is it restricted to
just those with universal credit
universal
chair i i can't answer the question all
i know is that's the government plateau
so that's the criteria the kickstart
scheme is set up on it's not a locally
normal decision just a bit short-sighted
doesn't it because there will be others
university
how are the business advisors picked and
chosen
[Music]
how are the business advisors chosen
to advise are they taken from within
north seven plus or are they taken from
outside of north seven plus and how are
they qualified thank you
so the business advisors that we're
currently using are employed by north
devon plus and in the past i can't tell
you the exact um qualifications of the
team members but there was a
business advice qualification called
steady and i
recall that certainly one team when i
recruited them
was steadily accredited at that time and
that was the measure of their quality
and business support now we're currently
looking to hire two
additional
people on a
consultancy basis so they'll provide day
rates for the business uh again i know
one of those has previously been
accredited with the same accreditation i
don't have the current quotation i'm not
sure about the second one um so i think
that's what answers the question they
are accredited business advisors i just
can't tell you exactly
i think they are yeah i think they are i
mean give everyone you know advice but
yes
so so i i think an observation i'd make
about the way north dakota
has been
criticized in the past for business
support would be that the criticism
tends to come from people that also
provide business support
and use it as a lost leader to create
business for themselves
so perhaps solicitors or accountants
um and they tend to be quite critical of
the plus because we provide a free
service
back in 2001 i was very accredited
and the test for it was the most
pathetic useless test i've ever had to
do in my life
uh having said that
i suppose technically i'm steady
accredited
uh
the
aggravate people i do know
um
they were very busy back at the mouth
time when the government had a scheme
they've been quieter since but now
there's another scheme so they popped up
again
uh
errol right
they're not fantastic they're not tax
experts which is the main problem
farmers have
um
but they tend to have a rough idea of
telling people where to go to get the
decent advice
it's a report for noting you've noted it
anyone else wishing to speak
no
right we can move on to item 13.
quarterly business
sorry david's been sat there waiting for
me quarterly business report pages 16-62
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
the quarterly dismissal reports for the
end of september supported soon so we'll
all review
we're projecting a surplus at that point
in time of 853 000 pounds
um some significant favorable variances
and a few adverse environments it
to have this projected surplus for the
financial year 2021-22
so it's under the key variable variances
the main one is planning income which is
meeting the level of income that we
received last year so we're forecasting
and
central government has provided others
with um coverage related grants sean has
alluded to the
business support grants and giving us
some monies for that some grants for
that and actually subsequent to this
report being produced there's some
further call with 19 grants that have
come in but
we're not likely to improve the
financial situation
um we've had a good year down at the
boroughs with the staycation and we
believe we'll be able to support our
leisure provider through the national
leisure recovery fund grant rather than
our wrong resources for this year
a couple of adverse movements
we underestimated the pay award and the
government said that local authority
staff
will investigate zero percent of the
public sector get zero percent apart
from those under 24 000. but now the
local government association has offered
1.75
to council employees
so we've underestimated the pay award
um
we got we went out to 10 for the tipping
off of our recycler to eat more in
torrent and that's that plus
the purpose of the report we're
forecasting at the um a surface 850
degree thousands reported to internal
viewing
scrutiny as you're aware you're going to
be getting budget reports you're going
to be probably sick of the side of me
over the next few months as i go through
the budget setting cycle
um we are facing
pressures going forward not least
leisure
and we've got a report to full council
next week on that
we're experiencing exceptional
construction price inflation there's a
capital event tomorrow
and that inputs primarily on our capital
programme
the government announced increased
employers national insurance
contributions to the additional costs of
social care so as an employer we've got
to pay dismantle contributions
the development peninsula pensions and
actuaries have indicated that when our
three-year
current deal on applied pension
contributions is reviewed expect our
employer contributions to rise
uh and as everybody's probably aware
there's inflation pressures in the
general economy in terms of like
utilities and fuel etc it's not a ford
focus 2064 plate is it that i'm sure so
don't need to steal that thing
thank you
so therefore i recommend the
recommendation to the committee is that
853 surplus predicts it as at the end of
um
a hundred thousand is um goes towards
the council's apprentice reserve to
support the apprentices essentially
let's grow it all we've got quite a few
apprentices and bacterium that i work
for now they've been quite successful
we also recognise that the council has
an aging workforce
and there will be occasions where it'd
be
beneficial to
recruit people while staff who may at
some point in the not so distant future
retire
that they're therefore that people can
be employed
and learn from the experienced employee
and actually we have somebody in place
when we go out to without having to
recruit
and i'll give you the example there's a
member in my team who's of a certain age
if i if that person decided to retire
i wouldn't i'm confident i would not be
able to find any like replacement with
the level of expertise and local
government finance so my
aim would be to recruit use this reserve
the correct session and graduate
planning reserve to train up an
accountant so at the point in time when
that person retires and already made
your placement available
and the main
purpose of the surplus is to allocate
six hundred thousand pounds to our
transitioning government funding reserve
without reserving exists to manage
uncertainty in our finances essentially
we balance the budget we've got a
shortfall between our income and our
expenditure we balance the budget by
using our transition government fund
reserve and to go back
i've alluded to all the pressures i
believe are coming
leisure
employer ni contributions pay award
our employer pension contributions
consumption price inflation general
inflation so the proposals that six
hundred thousand goes into our
transition in government funding
reserves boost the level of that reserve
so that we can balance the finance of
the council over the median term um
i'll have to take any questions for you
to the recommendation
don't you christy yeah and thank you
this is really interesting the the point
i'd like to pay for is on the last
bullet point on page 61
where you talk about 600 000 pounds
and it says uh this reserve exists to
manage the uncertainty in government
funding i'll report the uncertainty
[Music]
and we think we um subsidizing the
government yet again
um
could that be raised with rmp if you're
going to see him on wednesday
that
you know we've raised most of this money
when you look at the key
favorable variances planning the
borrowers we're actually raising this
money and yeah we're putting it into a
fund to subsidise the governments when
they cut our funds even more i suppose
the answer is it's a mixture i mean this
year
next year's settlement
in my medium-term financial
projection i'm expecting a small
increase in
our actual central government grant
because they're giving more money to
local government however i expect the
vast majority of that to go to our
colleagues at devon county council
because of the adult social care and
children's services and not so much to
come down to shout out district councils
like turret
the biggest factor if i'm being
perfectly on top of the medium certain
financial strategy is actually the level
of central government run per se there's
things like leisure
you know the employers ni confusion
which is granted is a
government policy to support adult
social care
inflation you know the construction
price inflation we have 10 percent so
the cost of new build that has a big
impact on our capital program so
the answer is
it's more complicated than just saying
it's purely a central government ranking
there are other pressures inherently
building up and so it looks like a
perfect storm coming our way
so even though we've got a favorable
government settlement we i don't
remember the last thing of themselves to
be perfectly honest but even we've got a
fairly faithful government settlement i
still think it's quite difficult times i
heard
thank you and i presume the government
figures will come out on christmas eve
i believe the 15th 16th of september was
the best destination
did i say sometimes december i do
apologize
16th of december is um the best
indication i've had today
i've not got a direct line to
ministers
in fairness the government transfer
christian they have spread of poverty on
the public crisis in the last 18 months
it's got to come back from somewhere
well people they're giving contracts too
might give some money yeah and look what
we're missing out
with replacement money
right anyone else with him to speak
yeah come to lebron oh yeah can you just
have clarification on what the uh state
of eden was in torrington
yeah south street i believe
yeah
i think maybe my colleague stacy maybe
give you a little bit more detail on i
believe it was the right way of a car
park
so we haven't disposed of anything i
think it was a property
nearby needed a right of way so we
granted that right away in return of
money
secondary captain hodgson
no one else wishing to speak i'll put it
to the vote those in favor please share
that is unanimous thank you
right we now move on to some urgency
procedures this is for information i
think
um
the first one i would say it doesn't
have my signature on it
but
i'm very well no that wasn't mine but um
i would have given my verbal to it
anyway
there is an email
[Music]
anyone wishing to comment on
quickly there was a meeting plan that's
why we used the emergency procedure and
we did confirm it our approval not the
dissertation but with an email to say
that we did approve it
so
welcome to the staff
well right thank you
council 11. well yeah just a couple of
questions
where's this money coming is it
government
i see the county council running the
scheme
yeah it's um
it's come from the government they've
distributed it to devon county council
we've distributed to the local
authorities to actually pay the money
out and there's also been some money
given to the cme
um and uh to the schools with free
school meals so it's been shed up pretty
equally across the
district
did it launch
like
yeah it was five million in total at the
torridge have been given 88 000 to
distribute through the hardship support
fund
okay
some of the money are referred to
right
i think that is the end of the agenda
so i can declare